you
[Music]
is welcome please join me in welcoming
Barbara gross thank you very much for
that wonderful introduction it's really
a great ok it's really a great honor to
be here giving a keynote at a faculty
summit where the theme is is focused on
an AI at the edge it's a time where it's
really important for those of us doing
research in AI to think about what
capabilities systems have what our
methods can do what they can't do where
the challenges are and what we might be
doing in the future
and for everyone in computer science to
think about how we can design systems
that actually do good in the world and
don't do harm this is perhaps this is
Turing best-known conjecture about
building machines with intelligence and
by the way he equated intelligence with
thinking he thought they were he wasn't
talking about intelligence as being able
to do research that gets a Nobel Prize
so his most well-known conjectures are
about what he called being able to
participate well in the imitation game
now talked about his passing the Turing
test that conjecture that we would have
machines able to do that by the year
2000 was not realized but the conjecture
that you see on this slide was people
now regularly talk about machines as
though they were thinking of course they
frequently also ask what were they
thinking when they do things that don't
make sense
so about 5 years ago when we were
celebrating the hundredth anniversary of
Turing's birth I was asked to give a
talk at a training symposium and I was
trying to figure out what I could say
that was novel because people have
talked about Turing and written about
Turing and I decided it would be
interesting to think about if Turing
were with us now I mean there are people
who live to a hundred years if he were
with us now
what would he be adjust to the people
watching the clock this clock is wrong I
have more than I am not four minutes
over so you might want to reset it okay
they didn't hear me I'll try to keep to
my time without the clock okay so and I
of course no one knows what Turing would
say so got it
but I thought the world had changed a
lot and I wanted to put a challenge to
the AI community I hope that other
people would also do that so I still
welcome other challenges and this is the
challenge that I came up with and it's
really important to notice that this is
about working as a team member over the
long term not one shot deals not just
one question one answer we can do that
just fine and I also want to say I want
to it says here that you won't notice
that it's not human it's not to say that
the systems would be indistinguishable
from humans it's fine to know you're
working with a computer system but it
has to behave sensibly so I'll give you
an example from health care a smart
partner that searches documents much
faster than any human being could do if
it delivers sensible results passes the
test if it delivers nonsense it doesn't
okay why now because AI has really made
it out into the world this focus in this
meeting the descriptions of focus of the
summit all make it very very clear that
we now have AI capabilities entering
daily life so we really ought to think
about how the systems we're building are
going to work with people
another thing that's happened as AI
technologies have made it into the world
we see widespread investments in AI we
see lots of claims about them we see
lots of fantasies not only that you can
let your car drive while you play games
or watch movies don't do it I
we're not there yet but also in health
care in elder care and education and it
is crucial as we think about this to
think not simply about the systems but
about the people that they interact with
and of course we also have a lot of
nightmares I will say the nightmares are
not new people have been thinking about
building machines could a human being
build a machine create something that
could think that was like a person for
centuries goes back at least to the
Golem of Prague certainly to
Frankenstein and more recently we have
things like the movie ex machina so on
the one hand this Android dream set a
context for Touring's conjecture on the
other hand it makes clear that there has
at least in Western culture it's very
different in Japan by the way they think
of robots as cuddly by the Haitian and
I'll leave it as a as a question for you
to think about the cultural part so my
argument is if we want to get away from
the philosophical focus and Turing was
asking a philosophical question and away
from the science fiction of machines
gone mad to get real intelligent
behavior we need to think about building
machines that augment our capabilities
not that replace us or replicate human
intelligence so here's my quip we know
how to replicate human intelligence the
process is known to be fun
so product is babies even when they grow
up they have only human intelligence we
we don't need to build machines that
have more of that we need to build
machines that complement that and I'm
going to very quickly talk about five
reasons why we want to aim for
coordination and teamwork now the first
two are about how times have changed
since Turing then about our
responsibilities and then because we're
doing research we want to do exciting
research so that's how people use
computers in turing today one person one
machine now we have many people in many
places and many systems working at many
time
there are several arguments from the
cognitive sciences also just say a
couple briefly brain development we know
that in the first two years of life if
you don't have social interaction your
brain is smaller and it generates less
energy and you're basically cooked for
life if you don't have that social
interaction in time we also know that
language learning depends on
interpersonal interaction there there's
some wonderful work by Patricia Kuhl at
the University of Washington I'll give
you one example she looked at babies
American babies no exposure to any to
Mandarin taking looking at the issue
that was so we're all born for those who
don't know we're all born able to
recognize the phonemes of all languages
in the world by the time were twelve
months old we know only the phonemes of
the languages that we've been exposed to
in those first twelve months somewhere
between eight and ten months of age
English speaking babies understand the
difference between LNR and Japanese
speaking babies have lost that
distinction many other examples she
compared exposing babies between eight
and ten months to American babies to a
speaker of Mandarin face-to-face and
watching that same person on video the
Mandarin phonemes were retained by the
babies who had the face-to-face
interaction not by the ones watching the
video okay what about engineering well
if we want to build good systems we have
to think about the people that were
building systems for and how they use
their how their different cognitive
processes work I'll come back to
language later in the talk but here's an
example to illustrate getting things
wrong I asked my phone's phone I won't
say which one where's the nearest gas
station I got a list of sixteen I asked
which ones were open and it offered to
search the web for the phrase which ones
are open which would have not have
gotten me fans
I wanted okay I think it's really
important for all of us building systems
to focus on the errors of systems make
rather than bragging about the great
successes that they have because the
errors are telling us where there's a
mismatch with our expectations the same
thing is true of Watson jeopardy and I
hear that it's now proving true of deep
learning systems with captioning of
images so look for the errors to
understand where there's a mismatch
finally there's an ethical argument for
considering working with people
autonomous vehicles give a lot of
promise for there the potential is huge
I'm very excited about them but they
have to be able to work with us
otherwise they're going to run into
trouble and we've already seen many
examples of that as wonderful as the
cars are because we don't do what they
expect but hey we're here first we're
building them for us people are a pain
in the neck anybody how many people here
have tried to do experiments with people
really we don't behave very well but too
bad you got to deal with them and
finally there are all of these really
wonderful scientific challenges so let's
go for it I've listed some here there
are many many more the last one is
actually about the challenge of
designing experiments that let us know
how people work okay so I want to shift
now from the argument for thinking about
this to thinking about the research
there are many domains in which this
challenge arises many times with
teamwork I'm going to mention those and
then I'm going to talk about some of my
own work in developing foundations
theoretical foundations for modeling
team working and putting those to use so
education healthcare writing papers
driving we can think about groups of
people and groups of systems groups of
people that systems help the last two on
slide autonomous system human
collaborations and crowd work present
really interesting challenges where we
as people can teach machines to do
better but we have to design them so
that they'll learn from us and so that
we're teaching them things that are
interesting not making up not doing
boring things because they are stupid
okay so shift to talking about some some
work there are several different
theories of collaboration that has been
developed I'm going to talk about mine
[Music]
because it has some features I think are
really important but all of them have
most of the features that I'm going to
talk about so the first thing to note
about building systems that can be team
members is you have to design the
teamwork from the start and you'll see
that in the formalism that I show you
and it's partly because whoops
teamwork is not simply the sum of
individual plans
you can't take my plan to do something
and Eric's plan to do something
individually and just smush them
together and you'll see that now in the
theory that I'm going to talk about so
I'm going to this is all in English it
was actually developed as a formal
theory in logic I'm going to talk about
this as I give you these principles I
want you to understand this is not just
soft blah blah blah but in fact any one
of these principles doesn't hold for a
system you can show it will fail at
teamwork at some point in time so first
we need each team member to commit to
the team doing its job that a commitment
is framed as an intention which means
you have to believe that the team can
actually do the work you have to reach
consensus on how you're going to go
about doing it and on who you're going
to allocate subtasks to now that doesn't
mean that everybody in fact it
importantly doesn't mean that everybody
has to know
everything about what everyone else is
doing but you need to know about the
points of joints so not all the details
just with this much you can see that
there's a requirement that the group
have some decision-making processes they
know when they've come to an agreement
and that they have mutual belief of the
decisions that they have so we all have
to know what we're all doing in addition
to things that I'm going to illustrate
in with some examples of research are
that we have to commit to the tasks that
we're given and again that commitment is
an intention and you can't commit to
something you can't do that you know you
can't do so our systems cannot commit to
doing things they can't do
you also have to commit to each other's
success which means that you have to try
to the systems have to be able to when
they act to think about whether they are
helping us get our jobs done or
interfering okay so that's the
delegation challenges we're going to
talk about three different roles for
these theoretical frameworks first
assistant specification then design
guide and then is an analytic framework
and I hope that you'll take away from
this but not only are these roles but
each for each of these roles there are
different ways you could implement the
system so you could use machine learning
or Bayesian reasoning or gritting theory
or logical rules
it's the properties that the theory says
the system has to have that you need to
get into the system within whatever
implementations are going to use you
want to read you a quote from y'all show
um in a recent CA cm article when he was
talking about the usefulness of logical
logically solid series he says this
matters because it helps you build
software that's beautiful on the inside
and if the internal structure isn't
right if it doesn't cohere with how
humans think of the world you'll never
have a truly beautiful user experience
so I hope you'll keep that in mind
okay so first
serious system specification and I'm
going to talk about the problem of
interruption management so the shared
plan principle here is that you have to
commit to each other's success so if
you're going to interrupt somebody you
ought to have information that's
valuable to them to interrupt only when
it's useful how many of you have been
interrupted by dialog boxes warning of
you of things like your battery dying in
three hours that you don't really care
about now okay so just go forward
without me there we go so there are two
insights that we had about the
interruption management problem and
these are really these are insights from
Ajay Kumar's PhD dissertation work Ajay
is here now so first of these is that
when we're collaborating most of the
time most of what we're doing is
individual remember we break the tasks
down into subtasks we delegate to other
people and if we take advantage of that
near composability we can get
computational savings the second insight
is that we have to have efficient ways
of reasoning about each other's
activities even when we don't know in
detail what other people are doing so
let me look at the first this is work on
seeing that the problem can decompose
into individual actions and joint
actions and then actually designed a
formalism which you called merely
decomposable MDPs the idea is you're
maximizing a joint function you have but
you have independent individual and
joint action sets and you decouple the
transitions depending on whether there's
a dependency when you need to
communicate or there's things are
independent the result of this is that
you get exponential efficiencies in
computation time you can actually
compute things you couldn't compute if
you try to do it fully as a fully
coordinated system
okay second the second problem oops
it's running ahead of me oh I have this
fear it's an automatic advance okay so
that's that's an example where there's a
specification that you commit to each
other's success and that you and then
and therefore that you don't interrupt
when you don't have something useful the
second example I want to use is work on
what we've called collaborative
interfaces and this is in an educational
setting here the domain challenges we
have lots of interesting exploratory
software for kids in schools to learn
math and science and evidence shows that
by exploring on their own they learn
more than just being lectured at the
constraint that we get from shared plans
and designing these interfaces is that
you can't assign something to the
computer system that it isn't capable of
doing so the task allocation so we
looked at could we build interfaces that
would help teachers where we leave with
the teachers the things that they do
best
so having broad knowledge of students
and how to interact with them but
assigned to the computer recognizing
patterns and what this is what the
students are doing and I'll give you two
examples of this on the left you see
exploratory some exploratory system for
teaching middle school students
probability and statistics so what
happens with you flip a coin and on the
right you see a system for teaching
freshman chemistry what we did in this
work was to expand on planned
recognition algorithms the plan
recognition algorithms that have been
developed in AI up to this point we're
all algorithms that assume that we were
well behaved eighth grade children give
an exploratory software and not only
make mistakes sometimes
that's part of it so you have to look
for things that are not right
don't fit but they also like playing
around and exploring in ways that maybe
the designers of the system or the
designers of the problems hadn't thought
so the plan recognition algorithm had to
deal with those kinds of errant
behaviors and the result was that we
developed new plan recognition
algorithms so this is a place we're
taking on the challenge of building
something that worked well with people
we actually came up with hard scientific
problems these systems were both
validated offline by through surveys of
teachers and and finding out how well
they worked and also proving correctness
of algorithms one of the most
interesting responses for me happened a
few after after the summit a few years
ago there was a workshop won AI and
education and the chemistry faculty
member at CMU who had developed virtual
labs
said the interesting thing for him was
that he learned from the system how his
students were solving problems and it
wasn't the way he thought they were so
this is part of what a system can do to
really help in education but notice
we're not replacing the teacher we're
complementing the teacher
more recently Coby gal who's at
ben-gurion University who worked on s
caste and then did virtual labs has been
working and so this was plan recognition
in a very different domain teaching
seventh grade geometry where the
students are working in small groups and
they're chatting with each other again
the teacher can't listen in on all the
conversations and the technical question
was could you develop could you detect
critical moments in those student
conversations and alert the teacher to
groups that needed to be encouraged to
do something else can't do full natural
language processing of the it's not that
it's not just dialogue it's multiple
students talking at once at once but
they could use machine learning to the
text I was critical those critical
moments and they've just done some early
classroom validations that show that
when you
that using the software the teachers are
actually in intervening at better
moments and the duration of the
interventions is more appropriate for
what they are because they're not trying
to do too many things at once okay so
the third thing that I want to look at
this is my current research on health
care coordination and this is where we
use shared plans not for system design
at least not yet and and not in its
system specification way but to look at
what was going wrong in health care
coordination so the setting is a clinics
for children with complex conditions
this could be from genetic problems it
could be from birth problems it could be
from illness at an early age the
children see somewhere between 10 and 15
care providers no human being can keep
track of 14 other people some of us try
but it's really not possible so the
domain challenge here is could we build
a computer system that would assists the
care providers and keeping track of what
each other is doing I'll just make a
note that electronic health records do
nothing to help with this problem they
may exacerbate it and give you an
example in a minute
so this this little sketch just shows
you how much communication goes on in
different modalities among people on a
typical team you can feel very sorry for
the PCP in the middle who is like the
quarter pack and worse with no with no
technology to help them okay what what
we learned from looking at the work that
people were doing was that this was a
very different kind of teamwork from the
tightly coupled teamwork we had studied
before and then our series had
originally covered and that our plan
recognition algorithms were working in
so the first thing is the team is
relatively flat
the PCP might be in the middle of things
but he's not in charge and he can't
dictate to other people what to do
they're also loosely coupled which is
means that their likes and nearly
decoupled plans sorry I am NOT pushing
the button it's just working its
autonomous I don't know how it became
like lovely if she's not collaborating
well with me I'm not very good and I'm
not running out of run yet okay so the
bottom line here is this is where this
we have a new kind of teamwork what we
did before will not work so the first
thing we did having observed this by
looking at what people the care
providers are doing by talking to oh
wait I forgot this really great quote I
thought I have to go back to this
because it shows you what one of the
things that overall me or the graduate
student working on this learn from ask
the physicians that she interviewed was
was there ever a time that they couldn't
find the information they needed in the
electronic health record here's my
favorite example answer there isn't an
example when I wasn't missing
information and the parent the parents
say we need to relay information back
and forth so the parents who aren't
medical experts are trying to figure out
what's important to tell people we
wanted to see if the system could help
with that
so here is what shared plans would tell
you about this settings first is they're
going to reach consensus on the recipe
then we could provide support for people
not just making up a care plan on a
piece of paper that they put in a drawer
or the electronic equivalent but
something that's dynamic and active that
in fact takes into account that as the
child's condition changes the plans
evolve we could support communication
and coordination at the appropriate
levels so figuring out who needs to know
what win in order to do this we have to
solve a real
card information-sharing challenge which
is to figure out who needs to know what
when you don't have the complete plan
information so not only don't you you
know it's not only that you don't know
exactly what somebody else is doing so
the PCP doesn't know exactly what the GI
doctor is doing nor does the physical
therapist but you may not even know the
full set of plants you may not even have
the probabilistic recipe tree with a
probability over them okay so what Oprah
did was to look at this loosely coupled
nature and recognize it was complemented
by the extended duration of the work
that people were doing so it's not
one-shot deals and you can take
advantage of that to learn collaboration
patterns over time and from those
collaboration patterns you can you can
learn about task dependencies and task
allocation and you can reason about
information sharing
based on those learned collaboration
patterns well this need is not only in
healthcare but also in various kinds of
office work for example when we write
papers with each other how many of you
when you're writing papers are three or
four other people are sending email and
making phone calls and getting together
right as wonderful as track changes is
in Google Docs so what she did was to
implement this implement the mutual
influence potential representation in
the DOI algorithm for collaborative
writing compared giving all changes
which is what systems today do with
randomly filtering out some so you have
a smaller loads with personalized
filtering based on the DOI algorithm the
results very briefly were that not
surprisingly if you limit the number of
the number of edits you show people
they're more productive because they're
looking at fewer things if you base the
change so this is what's important about
the algorithm if you base
if you base the change on what you've
detected about interactions but between
the work that people are doing then you
get then its judged more helpful by the
writers and independently the results
are judged higher-quality by people
looking at what comes out so so this
personalized change awareness makes a
difference I'll just note here that this
is this work was really a wonderful
blend of AI and HCI and I think we're at
a time in the development of both fields
where it's crucial for them to work
together they split apart a long time
ago and it's really important to come
together so now I want to take a step
back and actually look at some of the
lessons from the research that I've done
over many decades in as a way of just
summarizing where we are with respect to
this collaborative work and also leading
into some discussion of dialogues
because there's so much going on in the
dialogue and language world these days
so the first thing so I actually got
into collaboration by doing research on
dialogue the first thing was that we
noticed that dial dialogues aren't
linear sequences they aren't random
collections they're actually structured
and you'll see an example in a minute
and the language that we speak indicates
the boundaries and indicates discourse
information at the root of this
structuring of language is the
intentions the purposes of the people
having the conversation and this is
maybe the most important lesson for
those of you who are working on dialogue
systems it's not just the streams of
words it's the underlying purposes you
need to understand to really participate
in a dialogue okay we then moved in
trying to candy Seidner and I and trying
to move from understanding this to
understanding how to model those
intentions and that's when I became
interested in collaboration
because you can't represent intentional
structure as plans of individual agents
you have to amass where shared plans
came from and then there was a lot of we
did it for dialogue and then the
mathematician friend of mine said to me
come on to do n it turns out and it's a
lot as any basketball coach will tell
you and it's a lot harder than two I
think there's a big challenge here at
the edge already with this work which is
how to integrate the principles from
shared plans for dialogue and
collaboration in a way that melds with a
data-driven ml approaches how are you we
going to bring these two together
finally from the collaboration to
loosely coupled plans I told you about
that research there is here also a
challenge which is how do we deal a
broader challenge how do we deal with
all the different kinds of teamwork and
coordination which have widely different
information sharing circumstances and
now before I move on to the next thing I
want to talk about which is the ethics
aspect of all of this I want to read a
quote from Zack kahani who is very very
active in health informatics and a big
advocate of using AI to understand and
support diagnosis he has a mother who
has a cardiac issue and he was
interviewed about this he said that on
the one hand it's really great to
collect data and use AI for that on the
other hand there are family and friends
and here's the quote AI may be good at
chess and go and it's developing
expertise once reserved for doctors in
arcane areas such as reading x-rays
radiologists might disagree about it
being arcane but anyway but AI does not
do well at understanding the wide world
is
picking up mood or subtle signs of
distress at convincing a resistant human
to listen to the doctor we don't need a
nag for that we need a caring village so
again an argument for the
complementarity of AI building systems
that compliment us rather than thinking
about systems that replace us or simply
replicate us so now I want to turn to
look at the question of ethics and I'm
going to do that via an example of a
child's toy and dialogue because as I
said in the beginning
AI is out there in the world we are
using it all the time on phones and for
search and in many other ways and it's
even now entering toys for children and
I think that really highlights the
importance of anyone building a system
with any AI in it frankly I think anyone
building a computer system that people
are going to use for anything other than
programming need to take into account so
this is a for those of you who didn't
see this article in the fall of 2015
Mattel announced a new Barbie doll that
could talk and Mattel advertised it is
your daughter's new best friend here's
an example dialogue taken from the New
York Times I have I teach a course on
intelligent systems design and ethical
challenges and the students in the
course bought a Barbie doll and found
the 300 pages of scripts at the Barbie
doll follow so there are many more
examples that are even worse than this
but we'll deal with this so Barbie knows
this kid has a sister and s what does
she do what what nice things does she do
for you the child says nothing Barbie
says what's the last nice thing okay
Barbie hasn't understood the word
nothing not in the script
it's this little word negatives are hard
anyone who studied natural language
knows that okay
the child tries to answer but it's got a
other kind of negative word destroyed it
Barbie says oh yeah tell me more the kid
gets a little annoyed I left that part
out more than a little annoyed and
Barbie says have you told your sister
lately how cool she is this point I
believe the child said that's it Barbie
so I forgot that part
okay so here's the thing this is not
just awkward but it raised I mean this
is kind of funny for us but the whole
idea of having these kinds of
interchanges with a kid raises some
ethical concerns and I'm just going to
talk about two of them or many more and
that one is expectations that are
violated with respect to dialogue
behavior and the fact that this doll is
as my philosophy student PhD said
philosophy PhD student teaching fellow
said unremittingly pleasant like no
human being I've ever met
kind of this emotional equivalent of
being too skinny
okay so language learning the dolls
designed for three to eight year old
children they're supposed to be learning
language and how we have carry on
dialogues what they're learning is you
just ignore what the other person says
and go along with what you're saying
this is not exactly what we would like
to teach three to eight-year-old
children boys are girls
okay how about child development and
friendship so unremittingly pleasant how
many of you are unremittingly pleasant I
didn't think so thank you for being
honest
I you know we don't want a
three-year-old to think she has to be
unremittingly pleasant on the other hand
we do want a child to know that there's
the penalty to pay if you're mean to
somebody and Barbie doesn't care what
the child says just goes along with its
script I'll just make a note here that I
have some worries about anybody who
thinks we should create the west-world
environment given that we most of us
would stop somebody beating a dog on the
street why do we want to teach people
that it's okay to do what goes on in
West world I don't know anyway all right
so there are other questions questions
about trust and creativity but I won't
be able to go into those okay you can
ask me about them later okay so it's not
just Barbie it's any approach to
dialogue that misses some of the key
facts we know about human dialogue and
one of those is that dialogues are
structured by purpose they're not just
linear sequences so here's one of my
favorite examples of why that matters
most of us were taught that a pronoun
referred to the last thing that it
matched in number and gender the last
thing that them in blue matches is
number and gender is kids how many of
you think that what this person means is
they put the kids away how many use Isis
have to see if you can raise your hands
how many of you think it's something
else
okay so here's what actually went on in
this dialogue there was some intonation
John came by and let the groceries stop
at you kids and I put them away after he
left there is no question you didn't
have a question about what's going on
now this is a narrative about groceries
I have to say I was in the airport on
Saturday my plane looked like it would
be canceled I called the MS our travel
people I could have had exactly the same
conversation but with being about travel
interrupted by saying something to the
noisy kids who are unhappy they're
playing like a handful okay so finally
the AIA log is not just adjacency pairs
it's Twitter conversations aside but you
know they have their limitations it's
not just question response pairs so just
from looking at this you can see some of
the challenges for chat BOTS open
domains are going to be harder and
closed domains because you have to deal
with many more kinds of purposes short
dialogues that look just like
question-answer pairs are much easier
than when you get into real dialogue
okay what are the roots of the ethical
challenges here well we already saw
missing dialogue capabilities it's also
the case that if you give people
something they have a tendency if they
think a system can do one thing they
will generalize to its being able to do
another so the last time I asked my
phone where the nearest ER was I did
this i right
gave a bunch of talks for Phi Beta Kappa
traveling around the country it always
could tell me where the nearest ER was
when I asked where I can get a flu shot
it understood what I said because that's
what it said but this is answer gave me
actually two different answers I don't
know why I can't figure this out more
importantly when I asked where can I go
to get a sprained ankle treated this is
the answer I got now it's not so bad
really to tell me how to treat the
sprained ankle but it would have been
really bad if this has been about a
heart attack
okay so so we need to get it right we
need to be clear about what the
countenance is and what it's not and we
need to take seriously this idea that we
can't build systems that commit to doing
something they're not capable of doing
but there are many other ethical
challenges that come up and they affect
us not just as individuals but they can
affect whole communities they can affect
the world at large and I have just some
of them here that I hope people will
think about privacy and security is
always brought up but there's also a
place where there's a clash of the
incentives for business and social good
and I'm really glad to see things like
the ether effort here at Microsoft and
the partnership for AI because it's
really crucial that companies think
about this so we saw this clash in in
the concern for getting more clicks and
selling more ads in the spread of fake
news there are also questions of justice
and an Eric brought up some of this in
his talk about bias if you're predicting
the future based on the past at the same
time that you're trying to change
communities and lower crime for example
so there is a clash between this
progressive cultural change you want and
the predictions that you're making also
and this this came up in a State
Department workshop I chaired last fall
here's great concern about who owns the
data and here we have data is not just
Google and Facebook by the way it's the
cars that people are driving who owns
that data how is it going to be shared
who's going to determine what
regulations there are and then there are
questions of equality and making sure
that the benefits of the AI systems we
develop are are spread around the world
and a building trust well there's a much
longer list the second thing I want to
say is that when you think about a
and Essex we should think not only about
not doing harm which is really important
but about doing good and it was recently
a triple AI spring symposium in which
people talked about many many different
areas including health care including
sustainability I was glad to learn that
MSR has an effort on AI for Earth and so
I think we really could all be thinking
about there's just many many aspects of
life where we could be building systems
that would be doing good and not just
worried about what we shouldn't be
building ok so then one of the issues
that people think about a lot and I
think we as AI people should think about
as computer scientists by the way this I
don't think this is just an AI problem
it's a problem of all the technology
that we're building is a bad job and
about whether we're replacing people
augmenting people or complimenting
people so let me just give an example
from the legal and policy arena where we
can think about things that already
computers are really great at like
document retrieval and search things
that they can do adequately and well
enough in some in some areas like
drafting straightforward some documents
and things that at least in the
near-term future they're unlikely to do
well like producing a new persuasive
foreign policy initiative so that's the
law environment the policy environment
healthcare is similarly nuanced as is
education so the idea that we're going
to replace doctors rather than thinking
about how we can replace them to save
money we could think about how to build
systems that will let there do but
enable them to do their jobs more
effectively just as we were doing it
with the teachers in the examples I gave
you okay so these are all high level
things I think there's some things that
as AI people as technology people as
computer scientists we should be
thinking about right now because these
are things we can directly control we
can't control foreign policy
and that's the question of the jobs now
not just in the future and here I've
just given you two examples one is
crowdsource piecework okay so people
working under what conditions who
regulates those conditions and how the
second thing is as we think about
designing systems that has some AI
capabilities we could think about and we
would think about them as complimenting
people rather than mostly replacing
people and when they are they can't do
it they just fail and then some what
some poor person has to take over and
make up for their failures which happens
to me all the time when I get an
automated customer care agent we might
think about figuring out a way to build
a system that would help let's say those
customer care agents do their job is
better so I would like people to think
about that because I think we can do
better than we have done so far so far
we thought about well could we replace
the person okay if it fails it goes to
the person that means the person's job
one is handling trying to figure out
what the other person really the person
who called in really wanted and how that
makes them happy now that they're
extremely unhappy rather than enabling a
person to establish a relationship with
somebody and then get them an answer
more quickly so let me turn to some
general ethical principles people have
asked about who should decide the values
and I think that's a really important
thing to leave with people not machines
I also want to urge people to stop
thinking about and help those of us who
are already working with the press and
others to get them to stop thinking
about robots taking over because it's
not happening anytime soon and it's a
distraction from issues that are
important now so I personally think we
have more to fear from dumb systems that
somebody has told us or small
then from intelligent systems that know
their limits and I know that Eric talked
earlier about unknowns and known
unknowns I think this is really a system
a really important thing to aim for is a
system that knows its limits so there
are different ways for handling the
ethical challenges that come up the one
we hear that most is regulation and
policy there's also design we can design
the systems differently and that's
really the main message I want people to
take away from here so we can design
systems differently one of the things
that many people are thinking about is
could we build in ethical reasoning
capabilities and that would be great but
it's hard enough to build in reasoning
capabilities so I think this is a
long-term aspiration certainly an
interesting research area but I'd like
to see us focus on design right now and
finally when we put systems out in the
world we could accurately describe their
capabilities Mattel should not have said
the Barbie doll was going to be your
daughter's next best friend okay so I'm
actually unclear whether this is my time
or the total time yeah okay okay all
right okay all right so let me this is
my last major point I said earlier the
teamwork capabilities had to be designed
in from the start
ethics also has to be designed in from
the start and to get it right in the
future we need to do two things
one is those of us who teach need to
integrate ethics into our curriculum
we're doing this at Harvard now we
experimented this past spring with
having a small ethics module in four
courses we're going to do six in LA in
the fall a quick example from my class
face studies a facebook emotion
contagion experiment on a Tuesday lots
of discussion of ethics by the way these
students 150 students applied for a
class of 30 so they really wanted to get
in and they cared about ethics 48 hours
later on Thursday I gave an assignment I
did an in-class activity on designing a
recommender system including needing to
list the characteristics of the users
they would collect after they reported
out I asked how many of them had thought
about the ethical consequences of what
they were the information they were
collecting none of them none well
actually this year won last year none if
we're focused on efficient effective
design with all the stuff you know
efficient code etc etc and ethics isn't
on the list it ain't going to happen so
that's the second part companies
building systems need to make ethics
part of the product design ok I will end
by saying it's not smart if it doesn't
work with us and we want it pulling
together not pulling against us
I want systems that make us feel smarter
not dumber and conjectures are really
important anybody whose early stage and
wants to know how Chomsky and McCarthy
discouraged me can ask me later they
told me what I was doing was impossible
or useless and when we first did shared
plans people told us to think harder and
we could do it as individual plans so if
you're young and you have a good idea go
with it we need people to take risks now
computers aren't Islands we got to do
this these are all the people that
helped me including the funders and I'm
happy for questions thank you
Thank You Barbara we have time for a few
questions there are people running
around with a paddle so if you have a
question please raise your hand and
please say who you are and where you're
from
hi Randall from UC Berkeley wait wait
where are you I didn't even call on
anyone here okay paddle three hi Renan
from UC Berkeley thanks for the
wonderful talk
I had a question about foundations for
teamwork mm-hmm you talked about how
you're designing it from the start is
really critical for successful how do
these them other higher-order social
activities build into that foundations
with the sort of the status today things
like competition justice you mentioned
ethics a little bit how does that factor
in well that's what for people here and
their students and postdocs to start
working on this number one over there hi
I managed by silently and design team in
their Microsoft Cambridge lab I spent a
lot of time with design students to
being a interaction design discipline
I'm wondering what way you think we
should be educating these students who
will be following the design part
involved it's really themes in terms of
both understanding AI and technology and
starting to deal with some of the
ethical issues that you're describing
that's terrific and I can tell you best
by telling you a bit about my course
which is that it's aimed at students who
have had one programming course I co
teach it with somebody who is either a
philosophy graduate student or next this
coming year actually a philosophy
faculty member I think it's really
really important to have somebody who
has deep expertise and ethics there with
you almost and let me tell you about
what we did at Harvard in the spring we
had a recent PhD in ethics meet with
faculty to talk about the systems
the courses and what they were teaching
and then find a particular example where
ethics mattered so for example in the
HCI class like they looked at
accessibility many apps are not
accessible to people who were blind or
deaf so they that was an issue that they
talked about
needless to say in social networking
they talked about fake news so you can
find I would that's what I would
recommend find there there gotta be a
lot of good people or philosophers in
Britain who have studied ethics in fact
the trolley problem comes out of Britain
by the way and really so make it an
integrated part of the design that
they're doing and the projects that
they're working on but bring it so I am
a disbeliever in professional ethics I
think that's if you follow these rules
you won't get sued you really really
have to go deeply to become a thinker of
that ethical issues okay number two hi
Gershon do blondes from MIT from Media
Lab I so one of the last things you said
was we need systems that make us feel
smart and I wondered if you could
comment on this question of kind of how
long it should take to learn to use the
system how easy should they be and I
asked that because I mean teamwork as an
example it's not something that no
seriously think we're well-suited for at
the outset we learn to work together
over long periods of time and as we
build these AI systems what if it takes
two years to learn how to work with them
or how should we kind of think about
that question okay
so first on systems in general I'll just
quote Don Norman who said for those of
you not in HCI a really important aged
person in the HCI community he said I
don't need a manual to use my toaster of
course that might not be true anymore
so I think if we so it's true that as
people we need to learn with respect to
each team how to work with those team
members I think it should take no longer
to learn
how to work with the team computer
agents than it takes to learn with each
other and that depends on the people
whether they've asked how much they've
been parts of teams before or not but
the systems I think we should design to
be the best of team players
so thanks the last two questions have
been from Cambridge and in continuing
that trend I think question number three
is from Cambridge as well no more
Cambridge questions after this hi other
Cambridge David Karger MIT hi David hi
and I guess alumnus of your 1988 AI
class so you talked about these sort of
foundational principles of collaboration
your your theory of collaboration and
such and struck me as interesting
because you talked about sort of the
need for consensus around goals and
shared plans and things one of your
colleagues might've student did some
really interesting work a few years ago
on communication with aliens and sort of
developed a theory about how you could
actually carry out communication and say
the communication was coming out was
happening even when the two parties had
no shared no shared goals no no shared
understanding of the the universe and
I'm wondering whether that sort of you
know how that relates to your arguments
that you have to have these these
consensus goals and bringing it closer
to home
think about user studies where our
subjects are often not aware of what
they're doing or are even deceived about
what their goals are how does that play
into what you were talking about so
remember what I said is this the
principles are violated you don't have
real team works so if the answer with
Manu is to do it justice is much longer
but he and I asked actually disagree on
when you have communication and dialogue
so and I would have to look at the user
studies to give you a particular answer
but it's not saying you can have things
that look like teamwork happen
accidentally but if you don't have these
conditions I can take that group of
people and whatever they're trying to do
and give you an example where it would
fall apart and they would fail so that's
the point of the principles it's not
that you can't like you can have a
system that looks like it's that's a
remember my point about errors you can
have a system that looks like it's smart
until it looks like it's really dumb so
you can have something that looks like
it's working like team work and then it
falls apart I can give you an example
from the 1990s at Harvard I love this
example women basketball the Ivy League
always sends one team to the NCAA
Harvard went first
their first match was with Stanford
because they were at the bottom and
Stanford was at the top
Stanford's best player I don't know tore
her ACL or something Harvard won the
game and it was played at Stanford why
because they had teamwork asked their
coach they could Harvard could lose
their best player Stanford couldn't okay
let's take one last question here number
two hi Melanie Mitchell Portland at
university hey hey I made a really great
suggestion that products that have AI in
them like the Barbie example should
advertise their limitations but I'm
wondering if you can comment a little
bit more on how feasible that actually
is given that many of the systems that
seem to be the most successful are the
hardest to understand so I'd like to
make it so so first let me say that a
system knowing its own limits is one of
the hardest problems I know of with
respect to the Barbie doll I'd like to
get to the first step of not being
deceptive about the capabilities that a
system has and the designers know so I
didn't say this with Barbie but it's one
of my quips about it most of us have
known three
year-old I don't know a single
three-year-old who follows the script I
mean does anybody if you do raise your
hand because I want to talk to you I
know a lot of parents who would like to
know how this happened
they always okay we don't follow scripts
that's why some of these chat pods have
troubles so I would just like them to
say look this is acute it's that you
know for a normal kid in a healthy
environment with great parents it
probably doesn't matter the Kittel throw
it away after two days I would like to
start with not exaggerating the
capability okay let's thank Barbara
again for her stimulating talk and
she'll be around for the next few days
[Applause]